♪
>> THEY LOVE MY MUSIC.
JOE BIDEN AND BERNIE SANDERS
HAMMERING THE RESPONSE ON THE
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK.
>> LABELING COVID-19 A FOREIGN
VIRUS DOES NOT DISPLACE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE MISSED
JUMP SHOTS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
THUS FAR BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THE ADMINISTRATION’S FAILURE ON
TESTING IS COLOSSAL.
NOR SHOULD WE HIDE THE TRUE
NUMBER OF INFECTIONS TO PROTECT
POLITICAL INTERESTS OR STOCK
MARKETS.
THE MARKETS WILL RESPOND TO
STRONG, CAPABLE LEADERSHIP.
THAT ADDRESSES THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM, NOT EFFORTS TO COVER IT
UP.
>> WE HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT IS LARGELY INCOMPETENT, AND
WHOSE INCOMPETENCE AND
RECKLESSNESS HAVE THREATENED THE
LIVES OF MANY, MANY PEOPLE IN
OUR COUNTRY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE
TRANSPARENCY.
SOMETHING THAT THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION HAS FOUGHT DAY
AFTER DAY TO STIFLE.
>> SO, DOCTOR, LET ME JUST SAY,
WHAT I TOOK AWAY FROM THE BIDEN
SPEECH WAS SORT OF THAT HE FELT,
IF HE’S THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE,
HE LAID OUT FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HOW HE WOULD RESPOND TO
THIS ISSUE AND ON THAT POINT HE
SAID HE WOULD EXPAND THE
TESTING, BOOST HOSPITAL
CAPACITY, CREATE AN INFORMATION
HOTLINE FOR PEOPLE, AND OFFER
ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
LOSING THEIR JOBS.
HOW DID YOU REACT?
>> TO ME, THAT JUST SOUNDS LIKE
OPRAH.
YOU CAN HAVE A HOUSE, YOU CAN
HAVE A SCHOOL.
YES, OF COURSE WE WANT TO DO
THAT AND TRUMP HAS SAID THE SAME
THING.
WE’RE GOING TO EXPAND TESTING.
MAKE SURE WE HAVE ENOUGH
PHYSICIANS AND NURSES ABLE.
EVERYONE SAYS THINGS AND I WANT
TO KNOW HOW YOU’RE GOING TO DO
THAT.
LISTENING TO SANDERS, IF THIS
WERE HIM HE WOULD DECLARE A
STATE OF EMERGENCY AND HE PUT
TOGETHER A BIPARTISAN EMERGENCY
GROUP FULL OF EXPERTS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE TASK FORCE
IS?
WE HAVE SEVERAL DOCTORS THERE.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN POINTED BY
OBAMA AND PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
POINTED BY TRUMP AND WE HAVE
EXPERTS WORKING ON THIS
TOGETHER, SO I, AGAIN, FEEL LIKE
THAT’S A LOT OF RHETORIC AND YOU
CAN SAY THAT YOU WOULD DO THESE
THINGS BUT THEY ARE NOT GIVING
SPECIFICS.
WHAT I WANT FROM THE PRESIDENT,
I WANT HIM TO TELL US IT WILL BE
OKAY.
I KNOW IT WILL BE OKAY BUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW IT
WILL BE OKAY SO I LIKED THE TONE
LAST NIGHT.
THERE WERE ARWICK SOME ERRORS, B
THOUGHT HE SAID THIS IS WHAT WE
NEED TO DO.
>> OBVIOUSLY THE PRESIDENT IS
NOW, AND THIS I TOOK FROM HIS
SPEECH LAST NIGHT, ACKNOWLEDGING
THE SEVERITY OF THIS CRISIS
WHERE AS PREVIOUSLY HE WAS
SOMEWHAT DISMISSIVE.
NOW YOU HAVE A SITUATION, JESSE,
WRITE THINK THAT THE DEMOCRATS
ARE SAYING, HERE’S WHAT WE WOULD
DO SO I THINK THAT WAS VERY
CONCRETE AND SPECIFIC ABOUT
ACTIONS THEY WOULD TAKE THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT DISCUSSING.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS DISCUSSING
IT, JUAN.
HE’S TRYING TO GET NANCY AND
CHUCK IN A ROOM WITH MITCH AND
SOLVE THE PROBLEM AND THAT’S
WHAT WALL STREET WANTS.
THEY WANT A FIX AND RIGHT NOW,
BOTH SIDES IN WASHINGTON WON’T
PUT THEIR KNIVES DOWN AND FIX
IT.
EVERYTHING JOE BIDEN READ OFF
THAT TELEPROMPTER WERE THINGS
THE PRESIDENT IS DOING.
I WASN’T BLOWN AWAY BY BIDEN’S
SPEECH AT ALL.
I’LL GIVE HIM THIS.
TESTING CAPACITY IS NOT WHERE IT
NEEDS TO BE.
THAT’S ON THE CDC.
THEY HAVE PLENTY OF MONEY.
>> HERE’S THE CRITICISM.
HERE’S WHAT JOE SAID.
THIS WAS A FOREIGN BORN VIRUS,
YOU CAN’T SAY THAT?
THE VIRUS IS FROM CHINA, A
FOREIGN COUNTRY.
>> NO.
HIS POINT WAS HOW DOES THAT HELP
US DEAL WITH THE SITUATION?
>> BY CALLING ATE FOREIGN VIRUS
--
>> THAT’S HOW HE SEES IT AND IT
IS A FOREIGN BORN VIRUS.
JOE SAID THAT LAST MONTH.
IT’S FROM CHINA.
>> BUT HOW DOES THAT HELP US?
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN, IT’S FROM A
FOREIGN COUNTRY, YOU HAVE
FOREIGNERS COMING TO AMERICA AND
THAT’S WHY YOU SLAP A TRAVEL BAN
ON IT.
>> YOU WANT TO PREVENT IT FROM
SPREADING, JUAN.
>> AND CALLING HIM XENOPHOBIC
ISN’T HELPFUL EITHER.
>> ANOTHER THING HE SAID WHICH
IS RIDICULOUS, THE TRAVEL BAN IS
RACIST AND UNIT PHONE IT.
EVERY DOCTOR NOW ACKNOWLEDGES
WAS THE RIGHT MOVE AND THE
SCIENCE -- DURING THE SWINE FLU,
BIDEN SAID SOMETHING THAT SCARED
THE ENTIRE AIRLINE INDUSTRY, AND
JO GIVES, WHAT ELSE, HE HAD TO
GO UP ON THE PODIUM AND
APOLOGIZE ON BEHALF OF JOE FOR
SCARING EVERYBODY, AND HE HAD TO
CLEAN UP THAT MESS.
SO JOE IS THE LAST PERSON I
WOULD WANT IN CHARGE DURING A
PANDEMIC.
>> JOE --
>> I WILL SAY THIS, THOUGH.
>> I CALL HIM JOE.
>> DON’T CALL HIM LATE FOR
DINNER.
I THINK, THOUGH, I’LL GIVE
CREDIT TO THE DEMOCRATS, AND,
LISTEN, THEY ARE IN A POLITICAL
FIGHT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO WIN THE
NOMINATION OF THEIR PARTY.
WE’RE IN POLITICAL SEASON.
BUT I APPRECIATE THAT A
DEMOCRAT, IF HE’S GOING TO BE
CRITICAL THAT THEY COME OUT WITH
THEIR OWN STEPS, THESE ARE THE
FIVE STEPS I CAN DO.
THE ADMINISTRATION CAN SAY WE’RE
DOING THAT OR THEY CAN SAY,
GOOD, OKAY, YEAH, HOW CAN WE
WORK THAT IN.
WOULD THAT BE FEASIBLE, HOW
WOULD IT WORK?
ON CAPITOL HILL THOSE FOLKS
ALREADY ELECTED, THEY HAVE GOT
SOME PROBLEMS.
WE HEAR THEY ARE TRYING TO CHALK
ALL -- BOTH SIDES NEED TO STOP
IT FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
GET IT DONE.
GET IT DONE AND GET SOMETHING TO
THE PRESIDENT’S DESK.
IF THEY GET IN THE ROOM AMEND
HASH IT OUT, DON’T LEAVE
WASHINGTON, DON’T TAKE A RECESS,
GET IT DONE BUT REGARDLESS OF
PARTY, IF YOU’RE OFFERING
CONCRETE SOLUTIONS, GOOD, WE
NEED AN AIRING OF THOSE.
>> GREG, I THOUGHT, AS I SAID I
THOUGHT THERE WERE CONCRETE
SOLUTIONS.
THE BIGGEST ONE TO ME AND I
THINK I HEAR THIS FROM THE
EXPERTS, EXPAND HOSPITAL
CAPACITY.
>> I DON’T THINK ANYBODY WOULD
DISAGREE WITH THAT BUT THE WHOLE
POINT OF THIS IS TO COMPARE
THEIR PERFORMANCE TO TRUMP.
SO LET’S DO THAT.
NUMBER ONE, NEITHER JOE NOR
BERNIE TOOK QUESTIONS, SO RIGHT
THERE THEY FLUNK BECAUSE YOU’VE
GOT TO THINK FAST AND DEAL WITH
SURPRISES AND GO OFF SCRIPT
WHICH TRUMP IS GOOD AT.
NUMBER TWO, BIDEN LIED.
HE’S A LIEDER AND HE’S A TOOL.
WHEN HE OPENED THE THING UP AND
SAID THIS ISN’T ABOUT POLL SIX,
HE SPENT EIGHT MONTHS SAYING
TRUMP WAS AN UNFIT PRESIDENT AND
HE WOULD BE A PRESIDENT, THAT’S
POLITICS.
HE ALSO ACCUSED THE PRESIDENT OF
A COVER-UP.
THAT’S POLITICS.
SO HE’S A LIAR AND A TOOL AND
HE’S LOSING HIS MIND BEFORE OUR
EYES.
HE IS UNFIT.
IT JUST UPSET ME THAT HE WENT TO
THAT PLACE.
NOW, TRUMP’S WORDS COULD BE
BETTER.
BUT HIS DEEDS ARE EFFECTIVE.
HIS DEEDS ARE EFFECTIVE ENOUGH
TO BUY US TIME SO WE CAN PREPARE
AND ALSO TO PREPARE FOR
MISTAKES.
IF WE DIDN’T HAVE A ROBUST
ECONOMY AND WE DIDN’T KNOW AHEAD
OF TIME WHAT WAS COMING WHAT
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED WITH THIS
TESTING FIASCO, RIGHT?
I’M GETTING MAD.
>> WE DIDN’T ACT.
>> AT LEAST BERNIE IS REAL AND
YOU BELIEVE WHAT HE’S SAYING.
JOE IS A CARDBOARD CONTRAPTION
STANDING UP THERE SAYING STUPID
THINGS ABOUT IT’S RACIST AND
IT’S A COVER-UP.
HE DOESN’T KNOW WHAT HE’S
SAYING.
>> I THINK -- DOESN’T KNOW.
>> YOU’RE AN EXPERT --
>> WALL STREET, I DON’T HAVE TO
BE AN EXPERT.
THE WHOLE THING FROM TRUMP IS --
IT’S NOT A PROBLEM.
IT WILL PASS IN A FEW DAYS.